I promise you [__] an album you've
been patiently waiting now today is
finally present I took my time with this
[__] I put my mind into every lock what
did you say about turning that said he's
so whacked with his opinion and so it
just doesn't even matter because it's
just not a good rapper so the fact that
he's not good rapper shows what he's
learned from write with what he clearly
surely doesn't know anything about Ralph
from the way he raps yeah but that what
they the way that that's my opinion on
his music I think a lot of people might
share anything they know everybody says
so
it says that's how I feel about his
music I'm not saying he's a long person
not saying he's a [__] [__] and I
say he's a [__] come on do city he's
the [__] horrible wife rapper
he's wack period no way around it he is
black in the dictionary wack explain the
dead and yes actually that who else
might be an epic Rousseau's women yeah
little beat Soulja Boy little be wall
time yeah I'm glad that that wave died
out like there was a time where he was
yeah yeah cuz it's no bars how many I
could have kept it going you know
I came about you to do that but you
whack